[Music]
and if it's so in particular so I'd like
to talk about Juliet programming
language in particular I'd like to talk
about what it what we think it brings to
the machine learning world and the
things that were excited about within
that that we're developing at the moment
obscurity how many people have heard of
Julie already okay that's that's pretty
amazing actually and if they don't hear
using it regularly or has used it in
anger particularly okay a few hands less
but that's good because you have
something to learn like in there so yeah
we've had a bunch of really great talks
today and we'll have more two more on
applications of machine learning I think
my laptop's gone to sleep
so yeah lots of talks and applications
all of which is very cool and if you're
like me then you might want to take a
step back and kind of think that other
tooling that enables these things right
people are able to work much faster and
easier than they could in the past
they're able to scale up to much bigger
problems and more complex things and
especially without having like get any
particular knowledge you know you don't
need to be a GPU program or anyone more
to make effective use of your nets or
machine learning which is a great thing
and partly that's because of
breakthroughs in technology partly it's
actually because of tolling has improved
so much over the course of ten years or
so and so machine any particular hour
point where you can kind of just pick a
framework and solve your problem and
then you're kind of you're you're going
right you're rolling but so iti want to
talk about fixing frameworks for a
moment before I start talking about
Julia and then we'll notice there are
quite a lot of these things yeah every
couple weeks there's a new wall hacker
news right so out of curiosity I AG like
spend an hour compiling a list of all of
these things that I could find anyway
and this is how it comes out there are a
few and you can see the the more
well-known ones in the last ten to Flora
next no towards that kind of thing some
less well-known ones all the big players
are Intel Nvidia even Amazon I think my
favorite one is this one right here the
canoe gunner all that work everyone has
one of these things right you have to so
yeah and by this point you're probably
expecting me to say something like Julia
hasn't even better one of these right
and you might be thinking of this exceed
these kcd there's always a relevant
water break we have a new one we have a
new standard which is going to come on
general news cases so and this is kind
of how people view the situation right
people view it as a problem that there
are so many of these things and it's a
good reason why it's a lot of
duplication of effort and it's a new API
to learn when you want to move around so
but I kind of want to examine that break
it down is there a problem can we have
like can we not just invest for us
intensify for example and make that
really brilliant
not have to worry about the problem ever
again right the problem is that each of
these frameworks does different things
well that's the core issue and so Gmail
Euron talked about PI torch compared to
things like tensorflow and caris and
that's a great example as I have here so
we have for example data flow based
libraries like tensor flow which require
you to specify the whole computation
graph and once you've got that you can
distribute it over multiple machines you
can paralyze you can deploy to a smaller
embedded environment and you can apply
all kinds of memory optimizations that's
all really great but having to know the
graphics in advance might be an issue
you might want to do some different
computation based on the data which you
can't do so easily intensive flow or you
might want to do things like hand them
gradients in a custom way for
reinforcement learning that kind of
thing is hydrent as a flow then you have
play torch right PI torch addresses all
of those problems you're just writing
Python code and they differentiate for
you that's amazing because you can do it
you know write whatever code you want
for your network you can do all the
control flow you want and for loops so
on
but then you have this thing of
struggling with optimization and I can
tell you someone who spends a lot of
time thinking about how to implement
these things this is quite a fundamental
trade-off it's nowhere near as simple as
just saying hey let's just add these
features applied order let's just add
new features to tensorflow this is hard
to do so it's actually a good thing in
that sense that people are making all
these libraries to explore the design
space there's so many different ways of
doing this thing the solvent stalling
problem each of which it's a different
approach in use case so we kind of want
to know explore that space and figure
out what the good solutions always in
that so that's a good thing the problem
then is that these things are also
separate everyone is an island right if
you're working with tensor flow you
can't say oh let me play around with PI
talks you have to relearn the entire API
you have to rewrite your whole model and
this is not using the best or it's the
job right if you're a data scientist you
love works with art probably because
it's great for that but it's not
something you used to write web server
instead you're a web server and Python
and maybe you have those do things
communicating or pythons grapes and many
things but it's not good for embedded
systems so you'd use another language
like C for that we make trade-offs when
we combine these things in different
ways that's what we're not able to do
right now in the machine learning world
and so you have problems you have
duplication of effort within the
libraries themselves you have problems
as you kind of go outside the bounds of
the given framework and you find that
you're working on problems on I'm
exactly the kind of things Google or
Facebook is working on that's quite
likely because you're not Google or
Facebook right probably and a simple
example of this and probably one that
will resonate with a few of you is
having data and weird formats right so
imagine this kind of thing tens of fluid
and very City trained ones have readers
very data formats of written C or you
have you know poison pandas CSV Reader
which is really amazing at first then
you get some web binary blob or you get
some data which in some way text format
so you have the part itself suddenly you
have to write it in slope Ison or you
have to rewrite and C and you have
that's just a huge amount of effort to
solve that kind of problem
so with that in mind I will start
talking about Julia so I could go into a
lot of depth about the features julia
has and the kind of the things it's able
to do but I kind of want to skip that
and just show you some of the
implications of it at a higher level way
I think that's more interesting and
there are a lot of tutorials and things
online at you wanna know more about this
the gist of it you can get from this
image it is a very high level Python
like a ruby like language and the key
thing about julia is that we're able to
take this code code like this and make
it very very very fast so for example
this function you can in the ruffle you
can say to Julia please give me the lrvm
code that you're generating this and you
get something like that and it's thought
doesn't matter too much as you can't
breed this but the point is this is 10
or so machine code instructions and for
various reasons it's very difficult to
do this kind of thing in other languages
so in Python for example even for a
simple function like plus you have to
say a plus B well is is a dot R plus
overloaded
is be DARPA sort of loaded is their
method took somewhere even if you get
rid of the interpreter you still have to
do those things because if you don't you
change the meaning of the program julie
is designed to avoid some of those
pitfalls it's science or performance
from the get-go and so we can get this
kind of real-time machine code and in
doing so we kind of break apart the
barrier between the high level libraries
who are working within low-level machine
code that's running and they start to
shows how we might solve our problem of
you know having to implement something
custom you no longer have to do that
rewriting and see to get that breaking
down this barrier actually applies in
more than one case so we can have a lot
of flexibility to do what we want the
julia goes in to compile it in
interesting ways so there's a cool
library out there called who is native
jo-jo which actually runs julia code on
GPUs so this is a GPU kernel written in
julia which can be used to element-wise
add two vectors and most of the time you
almost certainly won't need to do
something like this but the point is
that you can always drop down to the
lowest level and see what's going on
right most of you of course will want to
work with some high level abstractions
so we should for example we use a few of
these kernels we build up matrix
multiplication and addition broadcasting
it operations like limiting and then we
put those in our library and you have
libraries for GPU arrays and you can
build other libraries for things like
auto differentiation and things like
that
so one thing we notice in libraries in
languages where you have to write code
in c and then wrap it is you tend to
kind of end up control rating everything
together everything has to communicate
the C level and then you build the
wrappers the language on top of that and
because otherwise you get performance
hit at the language barrier because in
julia there is the language barrier we
find that more things can we split out
into libraries and so in this case we
have a GPU or a library in fact we have
several of them each with their own
features and the wrappers for other
libraries and so on
we also have a few auto differentiation
libraries these all will mix and match
right
you can grab these and you can try one
drive you
and feel around for what's working what
is in we already have six combinations
as possible you know trade-offs we can
make here but we don't need sixty
learning libraries to handle that and to
explore the trade-off space furthermore
further to that then once we've kind of
have these basic low-level tools we can
start building up and you can see how we
start to build up higher and
abstractions on top of this so for
example here we define the julia object
called a type and we define a forward
and backward pass that type just britain
in Julia code using those GPU array
abstractions this is a very very generic
interface for a machine learning model
to fall back paths right and we have
optimizers that will work with this
generic interface so you can fulfill
that interface with straight julia code
or with a custom GPU kernel or with
tensorflow or whatever you want right
and it will all mix and match again so
obviously in this case like we don't
always want to write this kind of
low-level code we were on a white right
high-level kind of mathematical road and
have the compiler work out that that
should be done in place and so on what
things like that so building further and
further on top of that we have this
library called flux which basically
allows you to treat julia functions
written not you know as normal julia
functions element-wise multiply that
kind of thing and treat them as data
flow graphs which allows us to do things
like differentiation and even things
like compiling that function to tend to
flow or to other libraries to run that
function on GPUs and so on and then we
can you can see that this does supports
both a forward and backward pass so this
is already something we can use as a
layer in one of our models and that's
kind of very straightforward this
probably looks at the moment a lot like
building a graph intensive flow as you
wouldn't Python they're actually some
quite significant differences and I'll
show you more of those in the demos I
have they drawn so once we have all of
those pieces it's just the case of
chaining together layers right and now
we have a model which can do something
like recognizing endless digits and this
looks very caressed like and it's
designed to be that way of course
because care
a great interface of these things and is
very simple and the difference is that
it's more flexible we can replace parts
of this this is all built up and Julia
which means that you can work with your
own abstractions for doing this kind of
thing if that's what you want no it's
all kind of transparent the whole way
down and mixing matching all together so
when you want to fulfill your particular
use case you can do that by picking the
pods that you want and during the way
anything you don't want and in fact we
have an example here where we change
together and a fine layer that we
converted this into flow within the make
set layer converted to an X net another
library like tensorflow and softmax
which is just a julia function and this
is something we can go ahead and run a
training process on something has very
something you want to do but it kind of
illustrates how easy it is to mix and
match different approaches you could
have a multi torch like library and
Julia and integrated with this get
optimizers for free and kind of play
around with those different things yeah
so that's the so that Sakura died it's
about that kind of flexibility and being
able to kind of build whatever you want
onto the woods there we don't really
want to have any black boxes we want you
to be able to dig into any layer and say
okay what what's going on here can I
tweak you can I change it meanwhile of
course you can use the best debris stuff
you can you tend to floor if you want
there's nothing wrong with that so yeah
oh and so another thing I mentioned so
what we what we tend to find in the
julia communities that will have people
who start using the language and a month
later
might be submitting patches to like
packages or to the core language on the
github repo and things like that and
implementing strange new kinds of arrays
like bits arrays and all that kind of
stuff and that's not really something
you ever find in an ecosystem like
pythons although it has a huge number of
great developers you tend to knowing
Python isn't enough to develop item
because biting numpy and Python itself
absord
are not written invited because Julia's
written and Julia
there's such a grad like such a smooth
transition from user to developer and
which has been a great thing for our
ecosystem so far so I want to tell you a
bit more about folks and the work we've
done there so I'll load up those demos
there's going to water is this kind of
readable so this illustrates this by the
way is our ID
it's called Juno and the idea with the
IDE was that we kind of really liked the
tools like Jupiter which allow you to do
a very sort of interactive data analysis
in a very intuitive way in let you
visualize things and plot and so on and
but we wanted something that was more
attuned to kind of developing code as
well as just doing a data analysis so
this is an IDE which has many kind of
Jupiter inspired features like yeah like
putting support and so on but also you
can work with files and don't want to
probe at them so it's a great text
editor and we've done a lot of work back
to min on a time in the process of
building this so we have a fairly
standard console we can type 2 plus 2
and get 4 we sometimes find we have to
wait for the compiler to run a bit the
first time but then after that we'll be
very quick we can do things like create
random array 5 sorry random an array of
length 5 and that's some data that we
can look at and browse through we can
also evaluate in the editor so that's
why the kind of Jupiter inspired stuff
comes in we have a source code file here
and we can just kind of step through so
I'm loading data I'm going to spit it
into a training set the tester
that might struggle a bit while it's are
trying to display onto one it is because
it's quite an old laptop hopefully it
will load up and so you can see again
like this is very yeah caris I coded
basic the same thing I had our before
we're writing this thing in terms of the
trainings and layers together so what's
interesting about this is a less kind of
the via find like this stacking of
layers in itself but in fact the the way
that's implemented so I can actually
drop into the the library here and I can
say okay let's look a flux to define
layers and we can see it's defined in
this very simple it's just a little
gistic regression so we have a weight
matrix on the bias and it's x times W
plus B right so all this is loaded up
now so you can see we're able to just
browse through these are a race of these
the data I've loaded up here is MS
digits which I'm sure you're familiar
with but in case you're not they look
like this each one of the digits is
represented is an array of numbers
mostly zeros because of the black
background and we have some output data
which is a one hi in college a defector
of classes which there's a visitor 3 for
example so very simply we can call the
the model that we built on our data and
gain answer we can convert that model to
tens of blue and also get an answer the
answer will be pretty much identical
because it's just doing the same thing
so yeah it's kind of seamless enough to
the to hard to even tell if it's really
going on but then you'll feel your GPU
heating up if you have one and or
equally we can do things like work where
the next item said
and that might be handy for example you
wanna system X now it makes it faster
for some problems intensive flu so you
might wanna try out makes an equity and
see if it runs quicker for your problem
right that's a useful thing to be able
to do I'll show you quickly I want to
show you the training process because it
takes a while but I'll show you quickly
the some of the tools we have so within
the IDE Giulio's obviously built these
very numerical intensive computations
that go on for a long time and so we
have some tooling to support that that's
very well-suited to the kind of thing
machine learning does as well so for
example we can annotate a for loop with
this our progress annotation and what
that will do is that will cause the ID
to show the progress as we go through
unfortunately quite small along here you
can hopefully see down here we're
showing you know how far away they were
given a port or epoch how far we to the
training process as a whole we've got
half an hour left whatever it is so
that's really helpful feature and
eventually that will expand to kind of
allow you to cancel training processes
halfway through and inspect what's going
on that kind of thing so yeah how would
we implement in the fine layer well I
showed you that it's very simple it's
just implemented as an x times of u plus
b we can write it with julia notation
very mathematical we can use Greek
symbols right so no kind of TfL mammal
or anything like that we're able to use
the notation we used to and very simple
this immediately become something that
we can done she ate so we have a weight
matrix and a bias we put that into the
affine layer which now has that weight
matrix inside is a parameter we make
some dummy data we call it and we get
some output in a real network we want
some kind of activation to squeeze it's
between zero and one so we just try
calling the sigmoid function into
happens okay now that's between zero and
one right equally run on Center flow
completely trivial to do so again like
what's the key difference from building
intensifier Gras
as opposed to like running Julie codon
center flow well let me show you what
the kind of debugging workflow looks
like if we're using this so I define a
slightly more complex layer it's like a
two layer perceptron so we have a first
layer and a second
we have we call the first let me
activate then we call the second than we
stop mics so we can Senshi eight and
convert that to tend to flow and then
run it and we have a shape error we have
a shape error because we were expecting
21 inputs when we got 20 right so that's
a fairly obvious thing often it's much
less obvious oh I'm sure if you've tried
to use this stuff you will have felt
this the pain of kind of finding these
things and what happens in sensor flow
as you get an error like this which you
probably recognize it's saying the error
happened in this node now as long as
you've kind of scooped lessly gone
through your low your graph of a
thousand nodes and named each one and
memorize the names of all of them this
is totally fine if not then you have an
issue trying to find where your bug is
so this does something interesting which
is despite the fact that no julia code
has run here it will run on tempered
form in GPU whatever i gives us a julius
factories pointing back to the point in
our code where the error has happened so
actually highlights aligned as well
that's standard with all errors we can
click on tier at pnc sort of a menu file
we can click there and i'll take us to
here and that's it's okay
yap so the error came from our second
fine instance here right we can click on
there and i'll take us up here and say
okay it happened in the mat bowl in the
second define layer so we've kind of
been able to drill down and find the
error very very quickly even better is
that sort enough julia had a debugger
which also working the ID so we can step
through this we see our input here we
can step into their fine layer and see
what's going on we can see our weight
matrix b x ro
step through that and you're done there
back to the GOP okay well now we've got
an output from the first one let's see
what the sigmoid function does scaling
between zero one okay great so this is a
very intuitive way to kind of see what
your network is actually doing and if
you you can use potting while you're
doing this and setup the kind of
visualizations that we've seen earlier
today but not as a special case just as
part of that the way the idea works
right step so again step in and we found
our problem which is a map mole between
two matrices that are size compatible so
they don't make sense and multiply
together so this we think will be a big
help in kind of debugging the more
complex models than you have I'll show
you something else
so here's a recurrent model based on MJ
capacities recurrent neural networks
demo which takes a character at a time
as input from a text dataset like a
Shakespeare play and tries to predict
the next character using its state that
it's built up and so we train this
character by character we can teach it
to produce text which has that kind of
style so it's not similar to the style
transfer we saw early on but something
like that for for text how many people
here have worked with recurrent networks
before okay a few hands so this is
something that's kind of not usually a
first-class feature within most deep
learning libraries but it's something
that we paid a lot of attention to in
flux so as you can see like use the
basic usages like Karis again you just
pop a lsdm in there you statically
unroll if you want to things like that
the interesting thing here is actually
the way that this lsdm itself is defined
so
this is the mathematical definition of
the LSP M right and doesn't matter too
much like you have memorized this but
you can see there's we using this
notation for multiplying the weight
matrix by the input by the states we're
using addition of vectors we're using
sigmoid function and most importantly
we're using this T of minus one function
to say don't use the current value of C
because it's not defined yet use the
value of C from the last time we run the
network and that's great that's like a
very mathematical orientation but no
existing deep learning framework can
handle this kind of notation right you
have to do unrolling or you have to do
something else is very unwieldy and
usually takes you know gives a good
couple hundred lines to implement in
flux inside the standard library we have
this and we have a notation for
recurrent networks which as you can see
looks almost exactly like the
mathematical equations we just looked at
you can virtually copy and paste it from
the paper and so this file contains
three different Ellis recurrent Network
implementations instead of just the one
that you normally find if you look up in
you know the kara source code or
something so that's very powerful and if
you want to again like the the core
takeaways if you want to do something
custom it's very very easy and so you
want a bi-directional recurrent network
right you want to take the values of Y
not from the previous prime step but
from the next time step all right well
that's as simple as changing mr. platts
Mortensen to the minus one there's no
crazy acts going on here to achieve that
kind of thing so
so finally I'll go over a couple of the
case studies that we have so yeah
there's I can't I mean nobody's question
is this point this is all well and good
but kind of food who's using this right
who's actually being successful with
this already and so we have a bunch of
people who are doing that Julia gets a
lot of usage both within academia and
within industry we estimate we have
about a quarter of a million users at
this point and kind of doubling every
nine months or so not yet you know quite
a household Lanen for programmers but
certainly again there as we go along so
case study number one this image is from
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey which and
has produced about well a few hundred
terabytes of astronomical data from the
sky now this here is actually a very
very small static section of the sky
maybe I'm in a park or something like
that these little dots if you look
closely are not started this here is a
star these are all galaxies and if you
can see it and then you can see that you
know ones like this a horizontal and a
bit yellow and they'd ones up here which
kind of spiraling and red and that kind
of thing
there's something right here which I'm
not sure but it looks a lot to me like a
black hole if you're familiar with it
the a black hole is heavy enough to
actually bend the space-time around it
and the light coming past it will be
bent as if you know you put a lens there
so it's called gravitational lensing and
we get a warped view of this guy behind
so we can't see black holes because
they're pitch black so by definition we
can't get me photons from them but we
can kind of infer their presence from
this kind of image so that's kind of the
cool takeaway here is actually using
kind of the features of this image to
insert things right that's a core
machine learning problem and so there's
a project called Celeste at the
University of California Berkeley which
is doing exactly this and they're doing
in Juliet so they have built a huge
graphical model which goes all the way
from from you know what's a probability
of a given object being in the sky to
what kind of public distribution of
Unser's an MIT - what's the Poisson
distribution the photons hitting the
camera's lens right and they sweep back
through that model and they go then go
from photons to - stars and galaxies in
the sky using variational inference as
was discussed earlier today so this is
one of the biggest graphical models ever
run in a scientific context it's huge
and I going to be a bit vague about the
numbers because they're hoping to
publish this but the gist of it is that
this was running one of the world's
biggest supercomputers hundreds of
thousands of cause millions of threats
and they processed all of this data this
you know ten years of Sky Survey daegeum
fifteen minutes so that's kind of nuts
and it's complete julia code julia
threading julia data structures and
operations and all that stuff right
there's no framework that would like to
do this so we're like you've run your
code or supercomputer like this although
it could solve this problem of this
scale they had to write all of this
stuff from scratch apart from a bunch of
things that they could reuse from the
community like reverse biff right so we
have these tools like Auto diff which
are very generic so they can be used for
this kind of project as well as for deep
planning and it's all kind of very it
will mix it together well this is open
source amazingly so you can check this
out and you can like running on a laptop
probably not as quickly but you know if
you want to try it then give it a go
right and lastly I'll show you this so
this is another project at Berkeley
Berkeley they they love Julia apparently
so this is a autonomous race car the
brain of this race car is entirely
inside the car there's no remote control
server or anything like that and it's
entirely running Julia so it's using a
libraries of mathematical optimization
called jump which is one of the areas
where we state-of-the-art because people
have worked on this stuff for a while
and it's using that to drive itself and
park itself up in a in a tiny parking
lot so that's that's pretty cool
lastly I will
mention the julia computing website and
if you want to find out more about this
as a julia lying website as well on to
do computer and so on
this has all the case studies and if
you're more interesting like the
industry application there's loads of
industry stuff big companies are using
julia currently for to rewrite their
analytics and things like that as well
as julia pro which has the IDE in it and
this like while some of this stuff is
more plans we have all of the demos i've
shown today if anything they're like an
old version of a bug so all of that
stuff works and you can download and run
it today if you want it's not kind of
like some hand wavy demo'd i've just put
together so yeah i think thats that's
what i have so many questions
[Applause]
thanks cool features man i think the one
of the features from Julia is I believe
that there's a JIT right so you have a
function I can declare types and that's
the main speed up
there's ugly other lovely trick in
Python called number that also sort of
does this I remember a couple of years
ago I was doing some performance tests
with some very simple for looks and I
saw that number was a little bit ahead
in this space is I'm not sort of
declaring a competition here but what
does the main difference between number
and what julia does internally okay
throwing down the gauntlet Holly so I
got my intention story so it's a
completely fair question right and of
course if number is looking good why
would you you know that's not your
choice if you using Python right and so
what so there are a lot of J compilers
like like JavaScript v8 engine which
what's your code running and then try to
kind of optimize it after the fact I
believe numbers of that kind Julie are
slightly different in that it's actually
more like a very lazy ahead of time
compiler so it waits it waits until you
call the function to compile but then it
does the whole compilation upfront using
the information as so that kind of leads
to the other
and on top of that there are a lot of
kind of language features that are
designed for kind of so you have types
and objects which are designed to such
that you can put you can define their
complex number of type and put it in the
rain it'll be compatible with the C
version of that type and it will be it
will be fast as well right so control
over memory layout is something that
comes up again and again when people are
doing these big computations even beyond
like the micro benchmarks and forwards
and things like that on top of that like
numbers and amazing effort don't get me
wrong but it's worth mentioning that a
lot of people have tried to do this kind
of thing with Python so you have like
the unladen swallow project from google
pasted from dropbox and these are the
guys who made the 8 for javascript so if
you can make JavaScript fast then
they're there they're the experts are
the people to go to write but they kind
of gave up for those projects because
pipe is so hard to make fast especially
when you'd come to the C API and
interact with numpy and stuff like that
like it's hard to miss all those things
together so I have dogs it's a question
probably I can ask one more small friend
done and so far but with playing do I
know if it is fast right that's lovely
and all that and on one computer you
could do sort of things to make it speed
up well how good is to support nowadays
for having multiple computers aid in one
computation parallelism is really good
yeah also for multiple machines yeah you
can so this is watching built into like
the standard library of the language
itself you can like boot up an SSH card
Kuster have like some list of
credentials and say throughout this
machine in glucose and then you'll have
them working in fact like it's show a
quick demo I use the red book that's a
bit easier
so
let's try doing something really trivial
like a bunch of coins versus
I don't know we'll take a long enough
time so that one's let's try make it go
for about three seconds look too fast
okay this is a bit longer so free joined
some 1/10 of a billion random coin fix
then we'll get about half of a tenth of
a billion back
let's do ad books and this will simply
add two processes because I have two
cores on my machine and you might be
been warned up because I have hyper
threading whatever that does so
hopefully I'm not going to guarantee
this but
there we go ask the digit complaining
speed up fit it got down to more or less
half the time so this is this is multi
process already this is happening this
is communicating over a socket so having
me summon other server is just it's the
same thing technically and to that as
you can see it's pretty trivial to do hi
thank you is really a really interesting
talk particularly sort of that design
played offs my question is around is
Julia good for processing lots of text
rather than numbers and arrays of
numbers yeah yeah that's a great
question which I kind of alluded to but
didn't really go into another detail
yeah I mean that's kind of a hard
problem January but I'm string support
has more than the initial focus or
something it's improving over time and
but that's starting to get really really
good
so one of
one of the things we're working in 600
and trying to push forward is working
with data and Julia a data frames kind
of more loose data structures are
hundreds of agencies and so this is
something one of my colleagues is
working on Chesley gelda Julia computing
which just does CSV reading right which
sounds pretty trivial but CSV reading is
like an unbelievably horrible problem
because everyone does like use commas in
different places and like what start to
quote whimsical what is it what what
mark Secotan mill of a string that kind
of thing
that's totally inconsistent between
different things so it's it's a very
hard problem surprisingly and this is a
library which I think in recent times
big pandas and pandas is written just in
C code right through and it's very well
optimized pecos has been written over
many years by people who know what
they're doing so that's quite a
significant achievement on Shetty's part
and I wouldn't necessarily say that
beginner and Juliet could be pandas in
in two days or something because it's
just a hard problem to make this kind of
thing fast in general you have to know
that such a schema itself right but the
suddens possible kind of shows where we
are at the stage is there any more
questions
I wonder if you have any examples of
because you see able to bring these
demos tips of your fingers of its kind
of graphical capabilities graphing and
this kind of stuff okay I'll give that a
quick guys this the idea is something I
developed so I mean there's like a 50-50
chance that it doesn't work on a given
day but ah
I don't have the bottom library install
apparently let's see maybe we should
take another question while I'm just
trying to fiddle around with this I'll
see if I can get it working while you're
fiddling I was curious
where did they run this massive Celeste
simulation which machine um I'm not 100%
sure it should be in the paper or I
think and if it's not in the paper it's
reached and I got for the dolly so
yes sorry I only know because I used to
use the same machine in a past life and
they ran out on nurse which is a
supercomputing Center that's mostly
funded by the Department of Energy in
the US but it's based at Albion ow I
think and it's used for lots of
high-performance processing in physics
and stuff in the US by academic
institutions okay very cool thank you
okay
there's no more questions we run in a
bit of time but yeah yeah sure yeah I
can show you after if you're interested
in seeing poor thing either I have to
install the libraries it's probably not
worth like making it what is that so
yeah we can move on so negative I sorry
okay just wondering how powerful do they
use for graphic computations like
graphical errors in minimum Parker
brings over extended in memories our
fencing sort of that so I mean that's
that's exactly the kind of thing which
she is very good for in principle
because you can define your own data
structures and have good memory layout
and it's fast you know even if you don't
like that's the kind of thing we really
can't be done in a language without
support that kind of thing there's a
package called life graphs to jail which
I can point you to if you find the
afterwards which i think is supposed to
be pretty good by i'ma try to that much
myself
so I don't know what the different
trade-offs are there so but that's
probably the ones I look at see if it
fits what you need
that's great thanks for the doc thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]